den hatte ich zuerst tut mir leid den
hatte ich zuerst nein das kann ich
glaube doch nein ich glaube nicht
na gut das schönste schaden ich hier
gesehen habe dass ich noch einen davon
habe das macht dann zehn euro fiel
und da ist nichts mit vornamen
eigentlich heiße ich genial was steht
aber just in brasilien haben wir fast
immer einen anderen gegner und alle
haben einen spitznamen
ich hätte auch immer so gerne einen
spitznamen gehabt hat mir ein bekommen
aber sag mal kaffee kommt vor allem aus
brasilien oder davon könnte ich jetzt
nämlich ein gebrauchen gute idee
allerdings würde ich vorher lieber noch
etwas essen
ich sterbe vor hunger dass es eine noch
viel bessere idee
was ist eigentlich ein döner ein döner
ist eine türkische fleisch spezialität
mit zwiebeln salat und knoblauch
leckereien jede caribo aber was ist eine
currywurst dass seine bratwurst mit
einer besonderen soße carré das können
wir natürlich auch gerne isst was
irgendwie ihr euch entscheidet die
besten verlassen gibt es hier
sie erklären sich auch bestimmt was das
ist und vielleicht gibt es noch zwei
vereine